welcome back uh to another edition of
down the middle august of 2020 was the
last time that we sat down with leland
miller ceo and founder of the china
beige book
it's i think it's the most watched or
the second most watched down the middle
episode
we all want to know what's happening in
china we all want to know what's
happening with chinese u.s relations uh
and we want to know what's going to
happen in the new year and beyond so we
couldn't have anybody better to to come
back on the show welcome leland
[Applause]
let's take a walk back to down memory
lane
what happened after august august of
2020 in the chinese
economy and help
help the viewers understand
the sequencing of the virus
and what it meant effectively that china
was able to reopen its economy
as the rest of the world was shutting
down theirs
sure
so if we look back to the middle of 2020
which
feels like forever ago i
you know china did a miraculous job
getting back up
people back to work
factories up and running the economy up
and running
and uh it did a really good job of just
just recovering from the partial
lockdowns and one of the things that it
did immediately was register you know
we're talking about like weeks after the
lockdowns were lifted in a matter of
weeks
year on year gdp growth so you know we
knew this was complete
nonsense because we're tracking this you
know operating capacity at factories
we're tracking uh firms saying how how
well you know what share of their
workforce is back
the numbers were not you know they were
getting better it was an impressive it
was oppressive recovery compared to the
rest of the world but there was no year
and year gdp growth you know in the
second quarter of 2020 and the whole the
whole thing was nonsense
but before before you continue because
this was this was kind of a twitter
controversy at the time i i recall
that you were saying that because the
rest of the world continues to look back
on 2020 and say
china was the only major economy that
grew and you're saying that's not the
case so unpack that a little bit
right well particularly early on so what
what what what happened in the second
quarter there's no mystery about this is
the chinese government wanted a
you know validation for their approach
and they announced year and year gdp
growth which of course wall street
celebrated as his grand victory now look
they were doing the right things and
they did have a recovery but they pulled
all the gdp growth they would be
announcing for the rest of the year and
going forward back to uh you know back
to the second quarter when we finished
2020 we did not have positive
year-on-year growth from the year before
uh some of this academic now but people
used to say oh come on they're doing a
good job get you know don't don't be so
hard on them so look this is really
important because they're doing all the
right things and they're recovering in a
way that western countries simply cannot
do because you know
privacy and individual freedoms and
other things that the west won't
tolerate and they're still not back to
year and year gdp growth so we have to
understand that that despite the fact
that this this this government had a
very effective uh recovery from from the
early
days of the coronavirus they're still
having trouble and the way it takes off
from august 2020 or so is
we saw an industrial you know
industry-led recovery and the funny
thing is you know the government said
that too if you look at you look at what
the government said but we said all
other data at that time we're showing
that that the the economy is being
driven by manufacturing and property and
commodities retail no services no so you
know you had a very uneven economy and
where we where we sort of pick up from
the last time we spoke is that this had
gotten everybody who thought this grand
recovery was underway very excited about
the prospect for a normalization of this
recovery so almost universally the
market consensus was that you would have
uh retail and services bounce back to
sort of normalize this recovery that
would be going on domestic lead
consumption the way that consumer
spending surge you were going to see
that in 2021 now this was never going to
happen and the reason was never going to
happen is you know when we looked at our
data
sometimes you see things that are you
know some positive some negative and you
have to sort of tell a nuanced story
this was not a nuanced story our retail
data in the second quarter of 2021 when
most people almost everyone thought that
china was about to take off to a
consumer spending surge with some of the
worst retail data we've ever seen in the
history of china facebook you know you
not only had headline numbers that were
bad you had hiring was was was slowing
quite dramatically investment slowing
you were the lowest level retail
borrowing in a decade in the retail
sector so the idea that the retail was
going to take off and consumer spending
was take off it was never in the cards
uh and we talked about this and people
didn't believe us and then boom
what happened no consumer spending surge
and so this started to get people
panicked and you then had
the government
start their policy crackdown and you
both had she's tech sector crackdown
start and you had uh an rr cut which
looked like policymakers were on the
defensive
and so everyone flipped from thinking
this was the greatest recovery they'd
ever seen to being extremely panicked
about what china's prospects were so
this consumer spending surge didn't come
policymakers on the defensive rr cut she
getting she getting antsy on the policy
side so everyone got really nervous but
the one thing that everyone that almost
everyone agreed on is that well the
china's traditional growth playbook
dictated one thing they are going to do
big stimulus because they will stimulate
into weakness in order to get their high
growth numbers back
and
our response was no that's not what
they're going to do not because we had
some philosophical view on this either
way but because we looked at our credit
data and
nothing was happening so throughout 2021
you know people compare the leveraging
or the credit tightening in 2021 to what
happened back in 2016 2017 2018
totally different
nothing happened there was no
deleveraging whatsoever 2016-2017-2018
there were certain evidence of of uh you
know regulatory crackdowns there was a
little bit of it was a shadow finance
crackdown uh there were some little baby
things they did and you'd see certain
types of firms like state firms or large
firms or coastal firms borrow less for a
few months at a time but there was no
sustained leveraging you know slower
additional leveraging at best and there
was tons of stimulus there was enough
stimulus in
1516 to lift the whole world out of its
industrial recession right right and and
and people just labeled that
deleveraging and they they took the
chinese government's word at face value
on that nothing was happening of the
sort 2021 is fascinating because they
have really done a different job on the
economy there was real credit tightening
and when we look at at what happened
starting the end of 2020 but straight
through 2021 you saw
uh borrowing drop across the board you
saw loan rejection skyrocket you saw
every borrowing chart basically at this
downward slope and not just for a month
or a two or three but basically for the
whole year so what china actually did
was crack down in a way that they have
never done before nothing like this has
ever been seen in our data so while we
were seeing these extraordinarily tight
conditions which surprised even us
we were hearing the market say wow
lots of r cuts policy easing big
stimulus is coming no way no way the
opposite is happening if anything so
this was leading us to the end of the
year now when when when no policy easing
happened and it looked like the chinese
government continued their their strong
policy uh of
you know of continuing to keep you know
a a relatively tight credit enviro
environment
no one had any idea what to do because
they expected this retail bounce back
didn't happen they expected stimulus to
compensate for the retail weakness that
didn't happen people are pulling their
hair out because this was not the china
growth playbook that everybody knows
what this is
why why are they rewriting the playbook
well they're rewriting the playbook
because the china's you know china's
economic growth model was in an end and
the party realizes that not every
western analyst will acknowledge this
but what's happened is beijing there's
been enormous nervousness for years that
reckless credit expansion and yeah we
have this u.s and europe and japan
everywhere else but in china it's it's
even more aggressive since 2010.
with the reckless credit expansion
particularly in the property sector was
becoming such a worry that it was
uh threatening the potential for the
party to survive
in the long run and so what you saw was
a crackdown in 2021 first
financial sector de-risking and then
property sector de-risking and the
property sector de-risking everyone
started paying attention once ever grant
started a teeter but if you look at our
second quarter data before ever grand
re-hit the headlines we saw loan
rejections in the property sector
hit the highest level we've ever seen by
far and that happened again in the third
quarter and what that means is the
traditional banking system was kicking
out property firms was denying them
credit
and sending them to the shadow banking
system where they were more distressed
paying more for capital uh and that was
the sign that the property sector was in
significant distress and a lot of this
was was policy driven this is this is
the government allowing it to happen now
ever grand got caught caught in this and
you're seeing the property sector in
enormous distress right now but
all of this was
part of the data it was part of this
change and the reason to take this back
up to 30 thousand feet that this is
happening is that the social compact in
china is changing right now uh for
decades we saw the party promise the
people you know you support us and we
will deliver you high levels of growth
and we make you rich
and they can't promise that anymore and
they know it so what the new social
compact is is we will deliver you slower
healthier growth
we will make a stronger china and we
will distribute this wealth more broadly
so that everybody shares in it and what
social you know this this common
prosperity
change to the social compact you see on
the social side you see it in the policy
crackdowns with the attacks on big tech
and billionaire moguls and and others
but you also see in the economic policy
making and what we're seeing right now
is a paradigm shift the likes that we
have not seen in 20 years in china's
economy to much slower
hopefully healthier but much slower
growth going forward now the only reason
i want to put an asterisk in there
before your next question is 2022 is an
anomaly it's a political year it's going
to be different and it's probably gonna
for that reason will be cause a head
fake for investors because they'll say
okay well wait a second they're they're
easing conditions they're going back to
the old playbook 2022 should not be seen
as part of this trajectory 2021 started
it 2022 has to be easy has to be
uh looser for credit conditions in order
to improve market sentiment so that both
the olympics go off well but more
importantly she's coronation at the fall
party congress in 2022 when he appoints
himself president for life or whatever
it is
and then we can restart what is going to
be a much more precipitous slowdown in
chinese growth going forward after that
but huge things are happening right now
but because the old playbook never
applies most people who are china
watchers and have sort of lazily just
been just been uh every time they see
weakness call a recovery every time they
see a recovery they you know it's this
playbook that's played on for 20 years
it doesn't apply anymore and a lot of
china watchers don't know how to deal
with that well i mean we forget don't we
leland that world trade contracted for
the full year 2019. and that was driven
by
the the the growth rate in china
whatever that number is
you know slowing to a 30-year low i mean
you know
on a fundamental level well let's walk
through 2022 first but then we'll we'll
go back
and talk about
where that 30-year low is or is not if
they've round-tripped
but first let's talk about 2022 and i'll
tell you something i had a friend who
was in beijing recently
and he sent me a photograph and this is
just months ago but he sent me a
photograph of clear blue skies in
beijing
now why would there have been clear blue
skies in beijing when the olympics
aren't until february
you got to start early i guess i mean
you know the there there was a couple
things in place so you need to have blue
skies for the olympics they were also
really worried about commodities and
commodities uh inflation and other
things in
in 2021. um you know we started out the
year and the biggest questions we were
getting was that you know will china
export inflation no they were you know
it wasn't even close but you know the
worries were you know what is going to
happen inflation in china and will that
radiate out to the world what we saw in
our data throughout 2021 was actually a
much
more modest picture than i think would
be presented by these ppi and cpi
numbers uh inflation was under control
and and where we did see
very high inflation uh inflationary
pressure was in the specific commodities
to manufacturing to properties channel
and we saw that and it was affecting the
economy but it wasn't crushing the
economy and that was sort of the lesson
of this past year that said they had to
do a lot of things on the policy side in
order to contain commodities they were
shutting down plants and
and it had all these effects they were
trying to control the supply side and
control the demand side with an
environmental policy
on top of it and so it just things just
gyrated back and forth and back and
forth 2021 was very difficult year to
follow from that perspective but that's
one of the reasons i think that they
were shutting down
setting down some of their plants
earlier part of it was the olympics and
and blue skies part of it was that they
wanted to control commodities inflation
uh so it was it was it was an
interesting year so um
let's go but let's let's rewind because
i don't think a lot of people appreciate
that
while again while the rest of the world
was shutting down china was reopening
rapidly uh
they did a lot of stockpiling
in that in that time when the rest of
the world was in really under tremendous
stress
they bought a lot of commodities and
they were not buying commodities at very
high prices
look uh yeah yeah the the com you know
we track commodities as you know and so
we're track you know copper and
and steel and aluminum and coal and and
at the beginning of this cobit recovery
in china we started seeing the industry
just light up this is about six weeks
before
people start getting really excited
about prices skyrocketing but the
industry started gearing up you know
investment was going up big and hiring
was going up big and and interesting
reports from from firms on the ground so
you know we saw this start to gear up
where it got really really interesting
was after everyone had accepted that
we've got this commodities rally uh
going on in china it kept go prices kept
going up and up and up and you had a
bunch of firms on the street
including one that i pick on all the
time but i'm trying to be better about
this
they keep calling these ridiculous
commodity super cycles and what we were
seeing in this is that look if you're
looking in china
and as the genesis of some commodity
super psycho you have to be able to tell
the difference between what real demand
for the real economy is and what
speculative demand is and it's very
difficult in china unless you track the
data because in china there's a closed
capital account which means that you
have very limited investment options if
you're a firm or you're a household you
know you can invest in equities or bonds
or property
or commodities or commodities futures
and so what a lot of people do when they
see
the government or international
conditions signal properties potential
resuscitation or a big rally coming you
know they load on in and there's
enormous investment in the commodities
and it sends prices up and people who
don't understand chinese commodities
look at those prices and they say oh
look well look at all the demand they're
gonna supply supply and demand doesn't
work that way in china well i don't
think those people appreciate other
things i mean i don't think most people
appreciate that china has its own
commodities markets
that i mean i think that that's kind of
the missing link in a lot of the in a
lot of the thinking here
right and and and we were seeing
throughout the throughout this now look
there was a lot of real demand there's
no question right in this but at a
certain point we hit
this interesting time where prices were
going up but our reports from most of
these industries were actually very
negative they were getting crushed
because margins were crushing them they
started to gear down investment and
hiring and so if you're if you're if you
think that there's this commodities
price rally as commodities super cycle
originating from china and firms in
these major commodity sectors are
reporting pain and and worsening
conditions you know hold on there you
know it's not all about price levels as
a matter of fact the price levels get
you in trouble if that's what you track
in china alone so you know you had this
very interesting time in which in which
uh you know people were seeing this
dynamic coming out of china and they
were assuming because some big shops on
the street were we're calling this money
super cycle that wow we are on this
multi-year massive demand mega rally
china must be doing great and then this
starts to unwind and people start to
realize that they've been led down a
dark path by these predictions well that
was i mean that was one of the biggest
calls going into 2021 was relative to
the s p commodities had never been
cheaper and therefore and china filled
in that narrative really neatly
uh but that wasn't the case
well as with all things there was truth
in it but at a certain point
the the rally diverged from being this
this demand-driven rally and it became
the speculative excess and that's when
the chinese government you know kicked
in so we have a lot of commodities
clients and they were like
explain to us how to understand this and
i said look you're gonna you know the
government does not think that it can
squash inflation altogether it does not
want to destroy
what the commodities rally to the extent
that the commodities rally reflects
demand on the ground but it does not
like what it's seeing on the speculative
side and so it will cut into that so
as with all things there's a more
nuanced picture in china commodities the
people that got real loud at the
beginning of the rally calling for the
commodity super cycle uh
they they were wrong because you know
they they didn't have a nuanced view of
the fact that look for a while this is
demand driven then it got to a point
where other factors are kicking in uh so
if you you know if you were if your
prediction was the commodity prices were
going to go up and up and up for for for
five years or something you know you're
you're an interesting position right now
considering what's happening in china um
so um
talk talk a little bit about trade and
ports and imports and exports and
kind of this whole idea of moving the
global supply chain away from china
moving it closer to the united states
right so last check we've i mean chinese
imports are still kind of blowing and
going
yeah well you've got you've got a this
ridiculous story about the chinese
consumers rise which is never panned out
it certainly didn't pan out during the
pandemic everyone understands that but
this has been a marketing ploy by
investment banks
for as long as i can remember it's not
true it has not been true and moreover
the things that are being done right now
you know everyone looks at the property
sector and the bubbles deflating and the
government is actively
de-escalating property as a way of of
sort of pulling property as a growth
driver
of the chinese economy it's not going to
be responsible for the high growth rates
anymore they're trying to get a property
under control
and what the government likes to sort of
imply at least is that somehow magically
domestic
household spending domestic consumption
is going to fill that void so where
property once was okay property is going
away but families will spend more uh
well
that sounds great but what are they
doing structurally to incentivize or to
push that change you know nothing as a
matter of fact most of things are being
done structurally
right now
are
counter to that so how do you how do you
empower consumers how do you empower
households you know you you can
increase the you know you can make the
currency worth a lot more you put more
purchasing poc power in the pockets of
households
you can transfer state assets to
households or to the private sector you
know you can materially expand the
government safety net so that people
have to save less
uh little things are being done on the
margin for some of this but by and large
this is not being done and when it comes
to moving state assets
towards the private sector we're going
the other direction
so the government talks a big game about
how you know this this consumption wave
will replace this so the household
spending wave will somehow replace
uh you know other growth drivers
it can't because they won't let it
they're not incentivizing it so they've
got a real problem there can they afford
to can the chinese government afford to
expand their social safety net
well i mean i
they should i mean look
here's the thing about it they can
afford to do a lot of things but they
can't afford to a lot of things and keep
up high levels of growth so what we're
seeing right now is not just the light
bulbs going off because the light bulbs
went off years ago it's a recognition
that in order to strengthen the party's
position or at least make it less
vulnerable going forward they need to
start making these structural changes
and yes growth will go down and yes that
will be a shock to some people's system
but in order for the party to make sure
it's in a better position they need to
do it so yes they can put more emphasis
on on boosting the social safety net
they can do some more of this uh this uh
these structural changes but it it'll
it'll their price will be paid for it
and that's why we we look going forward
the idea that a lot of a lot of shops
you know they every time they hear a bad
headline they shave a tenth of a
percentage gdp point from 2024 that's
the wrong way to look at this the way to
look at this is we are going to see a
far more precipitous decline in chinese
growth over the next decade
2022 again it's an anomaly
2023 may gradually get into this but
they have already committed and i would
be surprised if there was a full
reversal they've already committed to
strengthening
both
the economy and the party's position by
allowing lower levels of growth and
that's what we're going to see 23 and on
so
in the middle of that there's 2022
and
year of the head fake year of the head
fake you're i'm gonna have to write this
down you're of the head fake
um
what are they gonna do
well they have to they have to improve
sentiment because there's no way in the
world she is going to risk a you know
negative sentiment uh in the chinese
economy uh you know worries over his
governance he needs to be going into the
party congress next fall in a position
of strength now what does that mean does
it mean they're going to reverse
everything they did in 2021 no but it
means that they're going to ease
conditions off a very tight 2021 in
order to make sure that people
understand that you know property firms
will be dying every day you know they're
going to cause some pain and they're
already we're seeing our data already
it's for weeks they're already easing up
on property firms to make sure that
supply chains there's not a cascade
effect
either down supply chains or broader
contagion outside the property sector uh
you know they're going to
uh they're going to have to uh signal
that there's going to be some more
police policy easing and and looser
conditions and more support to small
medium-sized firms they're already doing
a lot of this
the the stimulus will probably be front
loaded even more front loaded now
because i think that they're scared to
death of what the fed might do
but uh i think what 2022 is basically it
won't be a reversal of what we've been
seeing but it will be eased conditions
it will be improving sentiment in china
it will be convincing people that china
is uh is an investable location that the
conditions are okay and they'll be
support for for jobs and and uh and so
she will have a uh you know have a nice
coronation in the fall that's where we
have to go if conditions deteriorate for
one reason or another
either because
consumption falls off a cliff which by
the way we're not seeing in our data but
let's say that there's a big hit to
consumption let's say
the trade war re-escalates let's say the
fed does something that sends seismic
shocks to the other side of the world
then their their response on the policy
side will have to be more aggressive
because they are not going to let she
get embarrassed period
but with that said that doesn't mean
they're going to reverse course and
you're going to see a 2017 level
stimulus or or
or something we've seen in the past they
need to stabilize they need to improve
sentiment but they don't need to reverse
course so
why do i hear from certain corners that
xi jinping is at risk
that that underneath him is a layer of
very powerful
politicians who think that that he's
gone too far
and that he is potentially at risk
why does this narrative pop up from time
to time when i'm having conversations
with people about china
well i mean it makes for a you know a
sexy essay um to talk about look a lot
of it's true i mean there's no question
that she has been destroying wealth
particularly in 2021 he's been bashing
vested interests uh he's spent the last
10 years eviscerating his political
opposition and stealing their wealth and
throwing a lot of them in jail and so
there is opposition this eu jinping the
question is whether it's
it can rise to a level where his
future leadership is threatened now
i don't know anybody who can answer that
question with with any level of
certainty it certainly doesn't look like
that's happening
i don't think that's the expectation i i
understand why people
are
cautious about simply assuming that she
runs without opposition and he can do
whatever he wants that's clearly not
true there is some level of consensus
making the leadership but i think
there's no evidence yet that she has run
into any type of buzz saw that will
sidetrack him or you know threaten a
coup in the future
i've never seen any evidence of that so
i think it's smart to be nuanced in your
you know uh portrayal of his leadership
which is oh yeah he's strong and yeah
he's a you know there's a one-party
strong man rule but she is not without
limitations and uh and restrictions on
his governance so he that's that's true
but right now she also
rules the roost and i don't see that
changing anytime soon so when is the
congress and
if he prevails what's next for him
yeah so
they don't announce the dates until
closer to it but it'll be somewhere
around no you know november-ish uh of
2022. um
he presumably will prevail we have no
idea what he's going to do i mean he he
could say i'm gonna be president for
life he could give some some beautiful
uh poetic
uh you know plans saying i will spend
the next five years fixing the economy
in the five years after that
shepherding china's rise and then five
years after that i will decide i will
step forward maybe doesn't address it at
all he just sort of everyone understands
he's king
for life we don't know what he's going
to announce we also don't know whether
he's going to point successors so one of
the major problems and and this is
underappreciated i think is that he
the chinese system has worked a certain
way since since dunk show pain and that
is you know you get ten years
halfway through with the party congress
or the party congress we're talking
about is every five years and and at the
five year mark you appoint you know two
successors and the success and some some
some uh some younger cadres under them
to be the new leadership then they
compete
uh but mostly it's it's for ordained
who's going to be the next leader for
the most part and then you transfer
power every 10 years and this has been
thrown off and there are no successors
in waiting and it's been a very
dangerous thing
to be a successor in waiting under xi
jinping so we don't know whether he's
going to allude to the next generation
whether he's going to not which could
create enormous political
power vacuum in there uh you know who is
what happens if she gets a heart attack
what happens if he falls down the stairs
you know when he's he's reciting his she
thought and uh you know goes into a coma
i mean we don't know and the more
there's a power vacuum under she the
more dangerous this is so we don't know
what he's going to do there does he know
i don't know
but there's all these interesting
questions that need to be answered and
then once he has his third
maybe fourth and fifth in whatever term
secured i think he restarts
this
uh
restructuring program for the chinese
economy and he gears the narrative which
is important as anything else both
domestically and internationally towards
this slower healthier growth that will
assist china's rise and will be the new
social compact of the chinese communist
party
um
demographics
we're hearing more and more about
demographics that that is it is
impossible for the chinese economy
to rise
uh given
the one child policy and the backfire
that that's become
demographically uh
if if you're jinping how do you how do
you answer that
well the on demographics the ship is
sailed i mean you can see the the
incredibly belated panic they're going
through right now shifting from a
one-child policy to an enforced
three-child policy yeah uh encouraging
you know comrade just keep going more
and more children let's do it we the the
birth rates that they're announcing
right now are scarily low even in a
world that's seeing this these
demographic changes hit so hard um
china's and china can't reverse this
there's nothing they can do right now to
reverse what's coming and people have
said anywhere this could demographic uh
structural demographic headwinds that
could start next year they could start
ten years from now
the more important
thing to look at is that there's there's
really nothing they can do because china
got old before it got rich
and you've got other demographic
problems you've got too many men not
enough women uh the birth rate's too low
uh but the major problem you know in the
in the coming years is going to be the
fact that the economy is too old that
workers are too old you've got lots of
old people being supported by not to not
too many young people uh often in in the
grand scheme of things so
when you when you try to compare china's
demographic trajectory you know you look
for models what happened with the other
asian tigers well japan ran into a buzz
saw and now they're they've got a zombie
economy which is which is probably where
china is going you know 10 years from
now you know
ish but
they got rich first and so they're in
this weird twilight zone where as their
demographics fade you can actually have
per capita incomes go up as the gdp
falls and and other things slide and you
know
because you're a rich economy you can
sort of you can you can move on from
this uh you know despite the fact that
your that your population is dwindling
and
something similar happened to korea and
and taiwan got rich too china's poor
china is still very poor
and
there's nothing they can do about this
but i think that the there's a
realization on this i don't think
that this is western analysts preaching
to chinese leaders who have their
fingers in their ears if anything is the
opposite
you know one of the things that we've
been talking about internally and we've
been discussing for years with clients
is that
back during the trump years i think that
this structural
this this restructuring the chinese
economy would have happened back in 2018
or so
but
trump initiated a trade war there was a
decision at the very top in beijing that
the more pressing challenge was the
short term they needed to batten down
the hatches uh that you know they went
back to stimulus any kind of
restructuring reform talk stopped uh and
and
got punted down the road well we're down
the road now uh i think that they have
been worried about this for years
certainly people close to she have
articulated this like leo
who's she's right hand man
they have been very worried about the
fact that chinese growth is
unsustainable and so much of it even
shia said that a lot of
a lot of capital goes to these
unproductive uses which is going to
cause a drain on the chinese economy in
the long run because so much capital is
going to non-paying back non-performing
loans uh rather than going into
productive activity you're on a long
you're on a medium-term treadmill to
stagnation here and they know that and
they're trying to step in and fix it but
threading this needle is something that
no one can do even if they're the
greatest economic magicians in the world
doing this with by minute with
minimizing volatility and minimizing
social instability it's going to be a
herculean task there is no way that
there are not periods of significant
volatility in the coming years in china
as they
you know push this as much they can be
pushed
break something and then they have to
step back and uh and maybe um
you know
rethink some of this and before moving
forward again it's going to be really
tough
so um a u.s trade representative this is
months ago it started to look into
the fact that china
produces 89 of all the containers in the
world
and you know are our shipping rates
being
held at artificially higher levels than
they need to be is china sticking it to
the united states effectively
um
what's your view on this because it
seems like
it seems like the ports open and close
with
a little bit too much regularity
yeah and part of it is this one cove or
you know no covid policy um
that that stops things in its track now
keep in mind that when they announce one
case
there's not one case there may be a lot
more cases than that right the narrative
is if they've got three cases they may
have 300 cases who knows but you know
it's it's very hard to see through the
fog here because there are other
intentional things being done maybe
probably but how do you sort of separate
that from the fact that they're shutting
down containers and creating these
enormous quarantines for for for
for for transport workers and logistics
chains
i don't know how to see through this and
figure out what's intentional and what's
a byproduct of this this code supply
chain breakdown
are there problems in supply chains uh
overall
sure
um i think that one of the things that
that that the us is doing right now not
very well and extremely slowly
is identifying which supply chains
china has
a has control over has you know and you
have to run a gauntlet through china and
and of those which have a national
security component so i think when you
look at this like are there pharma is
pharmaceuticals do they fall in that you
know do ppe fall on that do you know do
um autos
yeah look uh so the question is where do
you draw the line it's been it's been
i've been i've been watching this
on the hill and it's just slow and
plotting and they don't really have a
sort of a a a a
set way to approach this so you're
seeing you're seeing a lot of talk about
supply chain decoupling but outside the
technology side which is which is too
slow to begin with but at least sort of
uh at least it's happening
you're not seeing a lot of consensus on
which of these supply chains need to be
actively reshored which of these were
just trying to kick out of china and and
and this is happening amidst a political
current which is promising reshoring
back to the united states but almost
none of that is going to be possible
your supply chains are not going to move
from china to the united states in the
vast vast majority of cases they're
going to move to china's neighbors
they're going to move to mexico they're
going to move to other places so it
doesn't help
pierce it's not easy to pierce through
the fog when not only is it unclear
what's actually happening but also the
political promises that are overlaying
this transformation are nonsense
so um china
just like the united states china has
made a lot of headlines about building
their semiconductor industry so that
they're
semiconductor independent so to speak um
how's that going
uh not well um you know it's interesting
because the long lead time
well the the the idea that the chinese
have been broadcasting is okay you're
cutting us off from certain ship making
equipment but maybe we can jump
generations you know if there's one
type of product that you cannot one type
of technology that you can't simply jump
generations by pouring more money into
it it's advanced semiconductors it's the
you know you know 10 10 nanometer and
below
ships that the chinese economy chinese
companies cannot produce now the one
thing that is receiving a lot of
attention it receives attention under
the trump administration it's receiving
attention under the byte administration
is you know to what degree
do you ring fence china off from not
just advanced tech but everything
related to chip making chips and chip
making and
there was supposedly a plan
under this administration back in the
spring they were so close to announcing
these export control reforms nothing
happened you're seeing some things
dribble out now so i think they're going
to be forced to be more forceful
in 2022 because there happen to be
midterms in the fall in the united
states and the republicans are going to
absolutely run on how weak biden has
looked on china so you're going to be
seeing a lot more on this but the the
idea here is chips are a very easy uh
very specific uh
product to a technology to evaluate here
you figure out uh what are the what is
the chip making that you cannot allow
beijing to get a hold of so it's dumping
it to their into their into their
military they're they're creating ai and
quantum computing and and 5g that's
competing or beating the united states
if that's the case and there's a
national security case for it you ring
fence it away from china and then you
don't just put it on the entity that you
know the department of commerce entity
list
that is not a black list
firms have have gotten around that it's
very easy to drive a truck to the
loopholes there huawei had its best year
ever after being put on the department
of commerce nc list because people in
the trump administration at commerce
weren't serious about actually cracking
down on huawei
what you do is you know you you utilize
probably trump's grandest legacy which
is the foreign direct product rule which
is a way of of
ensuring
that u.s technology does not flow to
other companies and countries
if it's going to be passed on to the to
to to the chinese companies that are on
a particular list so you can stop huawei
you can stop
smick which is their largest chip
foundry you can stop all these con
these companies from getting the
technology uh you just have to have the
wherewithal to do it you have to have
people at commerce who have guts which
is which is which has never been the
case or at least it's been few and far
between uh and so you have to and you
have to draw a line you have to say look
this is the national security line we're
drawing below that's a gray area you
know maybe big chips that go into your
your you know you want to you want to
you want to build a sony walkman here's
your here's the transistor you need for
that but you want to build a you know
a stealth plane we're not going to give
it to you so there needs to be lines
drawn there
and it's just slow going it was slow
going under trump it's slow going under
biden and that really those lines
that line making needs to be sped up
so
we can't really talk about
semiconductors and i'm jumping the gun
here and i kind of want to limit the
discussion to
taiwan semiconductor
if we could just to the company for the
moment because we'll get to politics and
geo politics in in a bit but how does
taiwan semiconductor play into this
because i i think they're the world's
most advanced
chip maker and they certainly have you
know
i mean they make i mean their market
share is enormous
yeah and they're probably the world's
most important
company if not then they're probably the
world's most important company that not
enough people know about so they have
one of those titles uh but look it's
interesting because
taiwan semiconductor makes the most
advanced chips
there are other
companies
samsung being among them they can do
some other thing at the top and intel's
trying uh but tsmc is is basically
at at the very top they are the only
people that can do this and
uh and so you have this issue where
taiwan is a political and geopolitical
issue for the united states but now
they're also a technological partner a
rising growing technological partner
with the united states and so the
importance of taiwan which has become
sort of amorphous in the eyes of many on
the hill and u.s population for many
many years
one of the things that taiwan
semiconductor and its chipmaking has
done has put a an actual substantive
reason for the u.s taiwan alliance in
addition to the fact that we have a
security commitment an amorphous one but
a security commitment to taiwan uh in
addition the fact that there are a
democracy and an ally in in in asia and
anything that happens to them will
redound
horribly for america and its allies in
asia uh you now have this this very
substantive reason why you need to
tighten ties uh with with with taiwan
semiconductor both because the u.s wants
those advanced chips and you want to
also ring fence those advanced chips for
the chinese so taiwan semiconductor is
extremely important it's it's
it's it's part of a tug of war the
united states has the upper hand on but
but it is
it's it's remarkable and how important
this particular company is
to sort of the future the next 10 years
of the of the of the the tech
competition between the us and china
so um
let's let's talk for a bit uh let's talk
for just a little bit about the property
sector let's go back and i'm not talking
specifically well i actually am
um
evergrand
can it be contagious
to global markets and you mentioned
recently that they've tried to tamp down
the property market
many times that this is not the first
iteration
of the chinese government making an
attempt at at tamping down speculation
in in the property market are they doing
anything this time that's different
and are they going to succeed
and
why haven't we seen any ramifications in
u.s
credit markets given that this is
theoretically after pedestal in
venezuela it's theoretically the second
largest
default in you know in mankind's history
uh well
so the proper what's happening in the
property sector right now i think is
part of this paradigm shift uh it is not
the
the the property slowdown of 2014 or
past years where we saw
things decelerate and borrowing slow and
then all of a sudden the the the
leadership got worried and then you know
reverted things back i think this is the
end
of property as a major growth driver for
the chinese economy not a growth driver
but a major one that they use in order
to you know
speed up property at the end of the year
so they can hit their high gdp targets i
think the high gdp targets are going to
go away i think the narrative of the
high gdp targets uh high gdp is going to
go away i think property is going to be
contained it will not be this this
downhill slope tightening tightening
tightening until all the bad firms go
away they're going to have to ease up
every so often they're culling the herd
they save some they call the herd they
save some so there'll be some ups and
downs and in 2022 there's going to be a
lot of ups in that because they're
already easing when we look at our
property sector data they're already
easing in the property sector to to make
things better and improve sediment uh
and to contain the worries um so i do
think big things are are changing going
forward
the reason that i don't think that this
has become a global issue is because
it's not a global issue
i was speaking to some senior people at
the fed the other day and i and i said
i hope
that you guys were joking about
china's property sector being being one
of your major risks you guys have a lot
of risks china's property sector
contagion from it is not one of them and
the reason for this is that
you know
for years we've heard that you know the
u.s went through its lehman and then you
know then the europe's had its problems
and so china's next
none of this probably i think people
know this now they've seen this is not
the case but you know early in this
there was enormous panic over evergreen
they're like is this china's lehman
moment no it's not china will not have a
lehman moment
and and the reason for this is unlike
the us unlike europe unlike unlike other
places
china is a non-commercial financial
system it has a non-commercial financial
system what that means is that when it
has a problem it can essentially just
take capital from one side of the of the
financial system and plug holes in the
other
and you don't you're not going to have a
counterparty freeze up that's that's
that happens with a sort of a lehman
moment because
in the chinese economy the government
owns or controls all the counterparties
so if there's a potential stoppage it
can order borrowers to borrow and
lenders to lend and suppliers to supply
and all the other counterparties to do
uh whatever it wants so you'll never
going to see a counterparty freeze up in
china because that's not the way the
system works
um
you you the risk is not an acute crisis
the risk for china is and has always
been
that all of these hole plugging
exercises
chasing good money after bed
dumping capital that should be used for
productive uses into paying off
non-performing loans and being dumped
into this black hole of non-produ
non-productivity what happens over time
is you have a stagnant economy you have
an economy that just slows down
um precipitously and and goes into japan
mode
and so the risk is not that you're going
to have contagion from the property
sector
enter china's financial system cascade
to the global economy that's that's not
likely at all uh what's what's much more
likely is that china continues to plug
hole after plug hole after plug hole and
you just have growth continually to slow
down until you've got an economy that's
completely stagnant
and that's what that's what she's scared
of and that's why they're moving forward
in structural reform because they they
think this is a good chance of happening
themselves
um
i've asked you this question before uh
offline
if germany had to choose
sometime the next five years let's say
whose side it would be on
um
would they choose china or the united
states
uh so we're talking about germany
specifically talking about germany
specifically
which exports more to china and
relies more on china economically
yeah i think the way they would describe
it from their perspective would be we
are fundamentally an ally of the united
states but don't ask us to ring fence
china because they're too important and
you know we're with you on most of these
things we share many of the same
concerns on trade on economics on
finance on human rights but don't push
us too hard and you know we see that
with germany and russia i mean german
germany's germany holds a very
problematic role in some in some of
these uh some of these coalitions but uh
i think that this is true for most of
the world i mean
i think that the united states can
marshal coalitions against china to do
certain things but it has to be very
careful that it is scoping out what it
is asking other countries to do because
particularly if you have china's
neighbors in southeast asia and others
and you're saying look join us in this
in this uh
pushback against
chinese bad practices they'll they'll
say okay but
you know we had to live next to china we
had to trade with china we had we had a
we got to swim in the same sea as china
you know this has to be this has to be
nuanced and i think one of the main
problems uh regardless of of the party
one of the main problems in scoping out
of china policy has been
clearly defining you know what our ask
is of our allies and those we wish to be
our allies when it comes to china i
think people are just starting to figure
that out
or think that through at least um before
we go to russia because we're going to
russia we're definitely going to russia
before we go to russia uh i do have a
question that has nothing to do with
well probably a lot to do with china is
india does india have the capacity to
become the next china
uh in a lot of ways it does um in india
has different but still massive
challenges ahead of it um you know it's
it
and you're seeing some of them fall
through the cracks right now with
protests you know modi promised a bunch
of things and farmers protests and he
backtracks so there are enormous
structural problems with india too
india has the capabilities of replacing
china uh to some degree i think it will
in the in in the supply chain and
you know lower levels of manufacturing
uh but
india india can't replace china
altogether um and india doesn't seem to
want to do what it needs right now in
order to be a
to advance
more so i a lot of this is is going to
depend on whether india reforms or not
and and there's some
there's some there's no highways there's
some positive signs there's very little
infrastructure in india i mean very very
very little in infrastructure in india
that's one of the one of the many
problems they have so we'll see india
india will fill that role to some degree
but i am not confident they can just
slide in there because they're not doing
what they need to do in order to in
order to uh to develop their economy and
infrastructure so let's ask the same
question i asked about germany um
first of all how are how's the
relationship between vladimir putin and
xi jinping
i mean i i
i don't think that there's really a
relationship i think that you know
historically you have to understand that
russia has been scared to death at the
chinese border so it's funny watching
you know us talking heads talk about
this russia china access as if it's as
if it's anything more than a uh you know
a way to sort of poke the united states
and poke the west and and try to look
like uh they're they're creating
leverage for themselves you know russia
is totally nervous about
losing half their country to chinese
going over the border they've always
been fearful of that so the idea that
they have these common interests they
don't um they can work together
and if they can frustrate some sort of
u.s platform they'll do it but um
this is this is these are not two
friends these are these are two
countries that
that look
nervously at each other and uh at least
one direction looks nervously the other
and um
and and
the headlines that you see from their
little get-togethers don't reflect this
but you know these are these are not two
friends plotting plotting world
domination they're they're pretty
focused on each other too
so uh are there allies that china has
that we should be worried about
uh
it's not about china's allies i mean as
a matter of fact one of the things
they've done terribly in the last five
years is capitalize on what could have
been good will
um you know people angry at at trump's
you know
you know trump's uh and anti-globalism
uh people uh people who could have been
to some degree thankful for the chinese
for sending around so much of their
vaccine to the world there are ways they
could have capitalized um on and created
some good will for themselves and they
seem completely unwilling and and un
interested in doing that um you know i
it was surprising the beginning i think
i understand it a lot more now they're
just so focused on the domestic
messaging that the world's keeping china
down
that uh and just rallying everyone
around the flag that they are
constitutionally incapable
of creating
good will so as much as the united
states does wrong china is doing more
wrong in terms of uh making friends and
influencing people and so it's not about
chinese allies per se i mean they're not
a lot of people we look at say
these guys are in bed with the chinese
and and we don't know what to do with
them
it's more fact that how do we marshal a
a coalition against chinese bad
practices uh without a splintering
because it's too broad
in what we're going after
so um
and it seems like this is just it's it
seems like it ever it's everybody's
talking about ukraine
everybody's talking about taiwan headed
into 2022.
and you know the the refrain is look
what they did with hong kong
they could just as easily do it with
taiwan
uh you have some different opinions on
this
well i mean i agree that what they did
to hong kong they would do to taiwan if
they got the opportunity uh certainly so
uh look it i think that one of the one
of the lessons for hong kong
particularly to the taiwanese people
is that
you know one country two systems is a is
a is a nasty joke i mean obviously you
see what happened to hong kong it was
gobbled up and swallowed whole by the
chinese state and that's exactly what
happened in taiwan so
one of the one of the problems with the
taiwan example for the chinese is that
there is no hope of convincing taiwan
that anything will be different they
they can either
they can either hold off in some neutral
in some in some in sort of a neutral
stance as a sovereign entity a de facto
sovereign entity but sort of keeping
that de facto
as as opposed to official and sort of
wait this out they can move closer to
declaring something which will probably
create a war situation with with uh with
china or they can come to some
uh idea that they want to be rejoined
with china which
is not going to happen doesn't look like
there's any support for that on the
island and so so basically what you've
got is this this this neutrality which
was going to have to last or this this
neutral stance in terms of taiwan saying
we are who we are china's saying
you are who we think you are and the
united states sort of
putting their own definition on it but
this this definitely upped the stakes
for taiwan because there's no there's no
going back to this there's there is a
there's there's their current situation
and then changing the status quo and the
station's the status quo will probably
lead to war so
things are a lot more difficult now than
they've been in in years well i mean
you've got i mean i don't think the
stories are made up that you've got
missiles flying pretty darn close to
taiwan i mean there is saber rattling
going on
yeah and it's and it's serious i look i
i'm not part of the crowd that thinks
that the chinese
leadership is planning their invasion of
taiwan right now there's a million
reasons to to assume and to you know
wait to think this is not going to
happen um the one reason it's not
completely nutty is that
everyone can can do their game theory on
china and if you do game theory on china
invading taiwan you invariably come to
the conclusion i know this because i've
done it many times
that
china will not invade taiwan not now
they can't invade now there's the
downsides are enormous the challenges
are enormous they may not be able to to
accomplish it uh
they haven't had operational experience
militarily for decades and decades
there's all these reasons why they will
not invade and i'm sure it's like not
going to do it in 2022 if xi jinping's
got his eye on november ish right well
so so here's the here's the the small
percentage chance why everyone could be
wrong on this and again it's a small
percentage but it's not zero
if xi jinping thought that his status
was being threatened that in order to
secure his term going forward his his
president for life he needed to make a
deal with hardliners
to move on taiwan or to move on protest
island or what one of these one of these
outer islands make a move towards taiwan
it is not out of the realm of
possibility that this could happen even
in 2022 because people can game theory
all they want on
china or beijing or the chinese
communist party but you gotta gain
theory on what's in shi's head because
he's calling the shots and if for some
reason something looked bad to him it is
not impossible that china would make a
move that's bad for china but
potentially good for xi and i do i think
this is going to happen very very low
possibility but it does deserve to be
articulated because in past years the
idea of china invading taiwan you know i
would sort of brush these aside this is
not realistic they're not going in
they're not ready
it's not impossible right now it's not
likely
that's not impossible i mean i don't
want to get too political here but don't
you feel like they're in a
a better position
given who is occupying the white house
compared to his predecessor
uh maybe i mean look the the worry under
trump was that he was going to sell to
sell out taiwan for soybeans i mean so
that was a worry it's the biden isn't
biden is it hasn't shown himself to be
particularly tough on china either so i
think yes maybe
but
but ultimately the answer is that the
u.s
populists do they want war no but will
congress and people allow for taiwan to
be invaded without without fight without
going to war against china i i don't
think so i think that regardless who the
president is regardless regardless which
party's in charge that if taiwan was
invaded by china the u.s would go to war
how how do people on the mainland feel
about taiwan
they think it's their taxes i mean i
think that you know it's it's you know i
i think that there is very strong
feeling that
uh
that as a texan i have to write that
down
this is our renegade province and stay
away from it i mean there's there's not
a lot of
back and f you know not a lot of debate
about whether taiwan is is one
satisfying there is a consensus a strong
consensus on the mainland that taiwan is
part of china and part of it's because
they've been drilled in with propaganda
forever and part of it's because
that's what countries do they want to
recapture their old their old glory and
and and
but i think that there's no question
that chinese
sentiment
on the mainland is
very much
um
it was very much
taiwan's part of course that one is ours
yeah
um
let's shift gears a little bit to the to
the u.s economy and to
uh
why the uh
why xi jinping is is scared out of his
mind about the fed
and what could possibly uh emanate from
obviously what we're anticipating is
being a more aggressive fed uh it seems
like jay powell
3.0 is is j powell 1.0 he sounds a lot
like he sounded in 2018.
uh yeah i think that the uh
all the headlines right now in the
financial media are
very negative on china they're talking
about how scary the retail sales data is
how scary the property sector mess is uh
you know china
is going to be forced to big time policy
ease because it's worried about its
economy i think those
uh concerns are over hyped i think that
by and large the big worry in beijing is
on the fed and how that will constrain
chinese policy going forward
and it's one reason why the beijing has
been moving up probably its timetable
for easing from early you know from from
from sometime in 2022 to earth to to
already to late 2021 because they
understand that it will be very
difficult to
watch a fed rate hiking cycle start and
be talking about easing policy because
they are so fearful of the lessons of
2016 when they had this capital outflow
crisis um and
that that scarred them uh you know the
currency devaluation which wasn't a
currency evaluation but which when us
went terribly has scarred them and i
think that the capital outflow crisis
scarred them and they have worked to
make sure this doesn't happen again so i
think the big fear next year is not on
this domestic weakness which is already
in china baseball data in the midst of
being
uh dealt with to some degree
and what they're really worried about is
the fact that they are going to be
constraining what they can do
from
from from monetary policy in particular
but but to some degree in fiscal policy
simply because the fed is going the
other direction and they don't want to
cause outflows uh so
this is
this is this is the constraining factor
on them and it's forcing them to move up
up their timetable i think for for
easing a little bit
uh
but i also think it's it's it's it will
further encourage the chinese to not go
big
on policy easy next year unless
they enter panic territory so if if
things start falling apart and markets
are crashing and there's a big china
panic then all bets are off but short of
that i think the idea that this domestic
domestic economic weakness is going to
cause the could cause the uh you know
the government to go big on on on policy
easing i think that's mistaken and i
think this is going to be a further
constraining factor on it they're going
to want to improve sentiment they're
going to want to
ease conditions they're going to want to
make sure that
that things are better in 2022
but they're going to be constrained into
how aggressive they can be and i i think
that's that's that's what worries them
not because they plan on being
aggressive but because this is going to
be a real constraint on their policy
going forward and markets are going to
know that well uh so let's talk let's
talk about the fed for a little bit here
um because
i can't remember i can't recall a time
in the last 25 years that i've seen a
yield curve
compress
as fast as this is as this yield curve
has compressed i mean it's been we've
gone from 160 basis points on on the
two-year 10-year spread to 80 like since
april
uh
do you think the fed is going to be
capable of
hiking rates if if this yield curve
continues to to flatten i mean we've got
a lot of we've got a lot of
fiscal
unwind
in
the works right now that really people
aren't talking about very much this
child tax credit for example is just one
of them um but do you think that the fed
can tighten truly raise rates
well i think it could raise rates to a
point
i mean you know there i think it will
hike next year and you know and
certainly i mean it's certain you know
and i mean look so it's signaling
three hikes or you know
can a kid do three i think you do three
hikes i understand i understand the fear
that things are getting broken i think
backstopping a lot of this is we are
definitely in in a
at least a temporary period of
semi-scary-ish inflation i also think we
live in a deflationary world so i do
think that and i do think that the the
way that the fed has looked on it it's
and it's made them look bad but to
defend them a little bit since nobody
else will these days um i think what
they saw is uh there are these there are
these temporary factors you can't say
the word transitory so i won't and
there's the supply chain breakdowns and
there's this this stimulus demand and
everything is creating this these these
major inflationary pressures but that's
not the world they're going to be living
in so how can they how can they pierce
through
um
part of this
without
flipping and then having to flip again
down the road or so i i i don't think
they've handled it well but i think
their idea is that we're looking at two
years of serious inflationary pressure
and then we're going to revert to what
is essentially this deflationary this
this global global deflationary
environment and we don't want to be too
far of our skis in that direction
i don't think they're going to be i
think they're going to have very limited
ability to hike um but they will be able
to hike they'll be able to get off the
ground and um and then
the big question will be what happens in
you know in in the end of 2023
in my mind
i know you look at this differently
well so where do you see the u.s economy
headed in 2022 given you've got a unique
prism up there on the hill
uh
what do you think the outcome of the
midterms is is going to
how do you think that that's going to
change the economic dynamic in 2023 so
walk us kind of
through how you see the next
year into the next year proceeding
so i think that the chances are
buildback better gets done early 2022.
i think that the
the fed is the fed is is is tightening
quite aggressively in 2022 or relatively
speaking um and i think that the
republicans crush the democrats in the
midterms um and i think the china policy
gets gets tighter um
throughout so where are we in 2023
i mean that seems like a decade away to
try to predict this time but right
but you see
why do you think build buildback better
gets well get gets done given it seems
to have been
um
pushed aside for the moment
because mansion is going to have to make
a decision
and the decision is how much you know
will he allow this to go down in flames
or will he take some pullbacks and
declare victory and the enorm there's
gonna be enormous pressure on him it's
by no means preordained that this is
going to happen
the agreement that has been agreed to by
the caucus versus what manchin will
accept are not the same thing so
someone's going to have to break
and the question is is whether mansion
is going to step up and doom biden's
program and so
pressure is starting already massive
pressure um they're going to have to
pull some things back um
it's not obvious that this is going to
succeed but i think it will i think the
odds are it will uh but there's enormous
headwinds to this because he is so
unbelievably important and he thinks a
lot of the things that are in the
program are bad
so the question is he's gonna he's gonna
have to figure out what he could what he
can digest and what he can't and if he
doesn't and bill back better goes down
then
i mean this could be the end of biden's
presidency
well leland
don't you think that manchin's not one
man alone anymore after virginia
i mean um in theory aren't there more
moderates
in the democratic party
in theory um but look i mean it depends
what how the how this is viewed when
you're when you're when you're going
through the legislative process you're
taking things out you're putting them
back in
your your viewpoint is i am a
representative from or senator from this
state
my view i have to be a representative of
what my state wants and what's good for
my state and that plays out until you
get to the very end and when there's a
handful of holdouts and then you get the
president calling and you get everybody
else saying look this is this is you are
going to decide biden's presidency one
way or the other
another level of pressure gets applied
um will that break mansion um we'll see
but i think the odds are this does get
done but it's not any but it's by no
means it's by no means a guarantee um so
but i think that the pressure on him is
going to be enormous going forward
um
let's let's shift gears
for just a bit um
back to
investing um
we've seen obviously this major
crackdown but at the same time it feels
like out of the other side of their
mouth chinese officials are
welcoming with open arms foreign capital
and there's this treasure trove of
trillions and trillions of dollars of
retirement assets
that look so attractive to
to u.s firms
um
how
bridge the gap i mean if you're a us if
you're a big u.s investor are you
investing in china do you do not fear
nationalization
i think it's less naturalization and
and it's more
fear that you can no longer properly
assess
uh the the political risk environment i
mean for years we have been explaining
the here's the problems with this and
here are the risk and
quite frankly
people would tell us clients would tell
us like we don't care like we're not
gonna we're not gonna worry about the
you know the variable interest entity
structure we're going to invest in
alibaba because if we don't we'll get
yelled at we'll have bad returns so this
has dominated for years and and because
of that a lot of
um
a lot of
uh investors were not particularly savvy
in china they just thought they had to
have investment in china in order for
them to have a you know a well-rounded
portfolio and to get those returns and
to get you know have those big big great
companies in their portfolio you can
look at it now and
obviously the last year has taught one
lesson which is
things that people didn't think was were
possible are now very possible because
the parties priorities are more
important than shareholders and that was
always true but now it's very very clear
that that can play how that can play out
in practice so if you're a if you're you
know when i get asked all the time is
china
investible or not and the answer is yes
but you have to have significant risk
tolerance to be able to do this if
you're a hedge fund trying to make a
profit then this may be a great
environment for you because you're
seeing values that are where you want
them to be but you're seeing a political
risk environment you need to synthesize
into your equation and maybe someone
like us or someone else who can make you
smart on china and then you can play
this in a way where you can make a lot
of money
if you are
a large money manager your pension fund
and your previous thinking was we have
to have the china story in there
everyone wants a china story that's a
really bad rationale right now to be
invested in china you will not have the
flexibility to be able to get in and out
you're not going to have the you know
most of them do not have anywhere near
the level of sophistication on china
that would allow them to see things
before they happen or react in any type
of of of real time so
the issue is is that if you're if you're
that type of entity china probably is
uninvestible right now and that's
completely separate from the reality
that we're going more and more from
towards realistic delisting a lot of
things that have happened and have been
threatened have been sort of out there
and they haven't been real they've been
people threatening you know delisting
from u.s exchanges but on some long
timeline you know as we continue to make
it more and more political what
companies you're investing in in china
the problem is is that there's no clear
line that if you're investing in chinese
companies and the party sort of controls
where those companies give the data and
civil military fusion is not some sort
of black line it's this grey line with
all the advanced
companies in the entire economy
it's getting harder and harder to be
sure that your investment will not fall
in a danger area where you will end up
losing money and i think we're getting
closer and closer to to a point where
nobody's going to want to defend the
investing into china thesis
um and
and you're going to get more and more
delisting and you're getting more and
more
um restrictions about investing in the
chinese securities so this is this is
going faster than i would have thought a
year and a half ago i i'm quite
surprised by how fast we seem to be
going down this line after it being sort
of a facade you know this mirage at
least for for years uh but we're but
there are real problems you know there
are there will be some decoupling in in
the coming years that that i probably
thought was unrealistic a few years ago
so um let's round up with uh with the
whole idea of the dollar central bank
digital currencies um
is is the central bank digital currency
a matter of national security for the
united states if china has one
uh maybe but not for the reasons people
think the reason to do a central bank
digital currency is because if you're
the largest economy and you're not going
to want to be the only you fed's not
going to be the only central bank that
doesn't have a digital currency when
japan has one and china has one and
everybody else has one along the way
they're going to want to be a leader in
this and it's going to happen it's just
the trajectory is sin it's going to
happen
but the reason to do it is not because
the digital yuan is out there and it's
going to you know eviscerate
the the dollar as a global reserve
currency
people get this so wrong they get this
so wrong the digital yuan
is a surveillance tool on the chinese
people and it will allow
in addition to being a surveillance tool
some very novel
things
for chinese economic policy making so
for instance let's say and the chinese
love to tinker they love to tinker with
their economy and so let's say that they
are seeing weakness in
tier four and five cities consumption is
really down
they want to stimulate but they don't
want money to flood into beijing they
want to do targeted stimulus well this
allows you to use monetary policy as
fiscal stimulus and what you could
essentially do is create exploding
vouchers so that people in specific
places or doing specific things or in
particular industries can see their
wallets fill up with spending money that
maybe expires in
four months or four weeks or four days
and they can create sort of explosive
immediate stimulus
with the push of a button
so what this allows beijing to do is
some really interesting things in terms
of micromanaging its economy and you
know beijing loads to micromanage
economy
the the scary thing about this is we are
crazy if we don't think that the fed
will be under enormous political
pressure to do similar type things i
don't have to preach to you about this
but i think as as central bank digital
currency if you sort of figure this out
there's a lot of ways this could go but
the idea that the central bank will have
essential control over all these wallets
and could you know let's say there's
disadvantaged
people in some industry in some sector
geographically or or or industry-wise
and and and some political forces want
those people to be rewarded
you're going down a road where the fed
is going to be
constrained or for or in terms of their
independence and so the the closer we go
towards the central bank digital
currency the more pressures against fed
independence they'll be i still think
we're going to have one because i think
that the the china thing will will i
think we're still going down that route
but i think that the problems we're
going to encounter are going to be
enormous and i don't know if the system
is going to be capable of resisting them
so i am very very worried about the
united states creating a central bank
digital currency
and it has nothing at all to do with
china
it has to do with
politics
politics yes and the fact that
there will be political forces who are
going to be pushing the fed to expand
its mandate even further i mean you
think you think solving climate change
is big this is going to be
you know
let's say that
people have certain characteristics or
live in certain parts of the country or
in certain industries and you know how
do you get money to them the fed will
have the ability they won't they may not
have the mandate they may not have the
desire to do this but there could be
enormous political pressures to be to
just to stimulate the same way that
chinese are gonna be able to and it's
gonna be a disaster the fed should not
be micro-administering
fiscal policy through a digital currency
but those possibilities open or they
potentially open
as you create this thing so i'm very
worried but i still think it's going to
happen
don't you think that that would place
the dollar at kind of an existential
risk
possibly but you know the the issue with
the dollar as as i think you're alluding
to is that the dollar
the dollar
could be
if anyone screws it up it'll be the u.s
screwing it up for itself you know
china's not gonna you know ascend to
global reserve currency status there is
no other
currency that in the coming decades
could become the global reserve currency
unless the u.s screws it up
and the u.s could screw it up and i
think that there will be enormous
pressures on them to do on on the us and
then on the fed to do stupid things and
that will eviscerate the dollar's
credibility if we're not careful uh you
know the counter you know the push the
push against that would be
at the same time other countries are
going to be doing equally or more stupid
things too so you know all you have to
be is the less
the least stupid
you know
shutting this down
so
um so yeah this is uh this is this is
one way could go though
all right well um
let's uh let's let's revisit all of this
after the congress um because i'll be
it'll be interesting to see how this
year pans out uh
and interestingly enough after the
people's congress and after the midterm
elections which are around the same time
so a lot a busy november we've got
coming up and
and i'm re-edified on china
all of the viewers will be as well thank
you so much for your time i really
appreciate it
it was my pleasure and i will look
forward to circling back with you uh
and uh you know grading our homework for
for how this uh how all my predictions
went good
awesome thanks take care
thank you
well i hope that you're disabused of a
lot of the myths that surround china
and a lot of the the hype
and a lot of the misinformation that is
spread about the chinese economy uh if
you enjoyed leland's uh interview go
back and watch the very first one and
see how very prescient his views are and
see how
unique a lens of a lens that he's got on
the chinese economy and i think you'll
thank me for going back and watching
that if you didn't watch him the first
time and again
you know always come to
coilintelligence.com i'd love for you to
look at the research as well uh leland
helps me with my views with china and
and i i share that with my with my
subscribers and until the next time this
is daniel demartino booth with down the
middle thank you
[Music]
you